[Music]
you've been uh shooting a movie out of
town yeah and that means you know a lot
of people who are not in the business
who think that must be glamorous it
really means a lot of hotel living yeah
day in day out so how is that going are
you are you hanging out in hotels
constantly i am i mean i was in portland
and it was very rainy so i was in my
hotel a lot and i rented the movie magic
mike
has anyone seen it yeah oh that's i
wanted to see what all the fuss was
about i was like i'm alone i'm gonna
turn on magic mike see what's doing
i'll tell you
i gotta say i have a bone to pick with
this movie it's shot so artistically
it's like all these artistic shots but
it's like get to the strippin
like where is the stripping it's like
it's very like i just felt it it's kind
of kind of like a sports movie like at
one point matthew mcconaughey's in the
locker room with like all the guys that
are strippers and he's like somebody
needs to get out there and start
stripping and like yelling at them like
we're sorry we're sorry we'll go it's
just it's a crazy and wait a minute just
so when they there must be a point i
even i'll admit i have not seen the
movie uh don't lie
i have not i have not seen the movie uh
you've seen the movie i saw the movie
yeah yeah
andy andy slept in line to see the movie
no i i i liked it mostly right no it's a
good one when i started to get into the
character part that's when i checked it
out yeah dude
wait a minute then what were you there
for
seeing dudes take off their clothes
but they don't really take their clothes
off like that's the weird thing wait a
minute it's a stripping movie where the
guys don't get completely new okay but
isn't that what happens all i'm saying
is and like every movie a woman like
takes her top off immediately they're
like dancing to it's raining men with
like umbrellas it's very sexy and then
they just take their tops off and like
stop and the lights go out it's like
yeah let's get to see you know let's get
to it
what did you want
what are you angry about what did you
want what did you want to see
i think i think she's talking about
flopping dongs
[Applause]
is that what that's what you're talking
about
it's not i had to go look at the ocean
for a bit to
calm myself from that it's not so much i
want to see it as i feel like so many
women have to take their clothes off in
and you think it's like an equal
time thing if women have to be naked
guys should have to be completely naked
okay i mean i wouldn't have minded it
yeah for equality for equality okay
all right but overall
overall good movie that's what you're
saying great movie i mean great movie
yeah all right ridiculous uh ridiculous
we don't have a lot of time tonight but
i have to ask you you've done so well i
i don't know much about your your
parents your family your parents must be
very proud of you they're very proud my
dad is very proud but he kind of gives
me my knocks like he saw i did this
covers it was called the washington
flyer it's a magazine that is displayed
in airports in washington and given away
for free and airport kiosks
and my dad was like hey that's cool it's
not vogue
yeah
yeah he kind of just had to let you know
right you tell me you know i was like
well i know and i was excited about it
sure yeah and you've worked with him
right have you ever you got him an
acting gig well he was a background
artist
in a movie that i did and the director
finally said to me you know he was in
the in like an audience shot he's like i
have to tell your dad to tone it down by
80
was he in the background just what was
he doing just crazy crazy like they'd be
like act sad and he was like
and they're like and now you're mad and
he jumps up and is like trying to lift a
table up and they're like bring it down
and i said to him dad man i've gotten
that note all my life yeah i understand
you you've got to relax